[Music]
you know ariana grande and Pete Davidson
aren't the only stars who got engaged
this week
dancing pros Val Chmerkovskiy and Jenna
Johnson did also and we have the latest
details I'm very grateful
all my dreams coming true he's the guy
for you you're so happy yeah so so happy
Val got down on one knee and made it
official with a huge cushion cut diamond
he proposed his longtime love in Venice
Italy the couple made the happy
announcement yesterday via Instagram in
a statement to ET today Val said he
first visited Venice when he was 17 and
quote I promised myself then that the
next time I would come back was to
propose to the woman I want to spend the
rest of my life with 15 years later I
kept my word it was perfect he hinted
about a proposal to us back in March
it'll probably be in a foreign place
somewhere very romantic yeah probably
without any cameras and away from
everyone the dance pros who met in the
ballroom first sparked rumors over
romance in 2016 we've had to go through
a lot of different things in life
together and apart and I think we just
kind of realized we're way better
together no word yet on a wedding date
one thing we do know that was ready to
be a day I can't wait to be a father
I probably can I'm more eager to be a
father than a husband for sure
[Music]
[Applause]